we got some big news big news
for spider-man three supposedly
all the main articles of all these
hollywood news sites are reporting on
this jamie foxx
still in talks to celebrate brie
larson's birthday
exactly john had that joke prepared the
second this new story dropped
it's time for my breathers greg gonna
say it so i can
say this big news here jamie foxx is in
talks to return
as electro for spider-man 3 the one with
tom holland directed by john watts
there's a couple of things we have to
make clear here first off i don't think
there's any
finalized deals yet there are people who
are saying that it's
complete that it's official i don't
think that's what the case is
from what we can gather they didn't even
exactly confirm he would be electro for
all we know he could be playing a
different
person yeah there's a lot of speculation
as to whether it'll be
the electro that we saw before if it'll
be electro at all most people seem to
think it'll be some version of electro
i mean good for him
[Laughter]
i he's arguably the most
dedicated like that's not the beloved
portrayal of that character but he
arguably looked the most invested in
that movie
this is big news in a bunch of reasons
that are for me
that are outside of jamie foxx returning
let me explain the idea of jamie foxx
returning as
electro like if this was amazing
spider-man 3
and electro was confirmed to return be
like all right
he was fine sure why are we
repeating that he's definitely a
character that gets clown on a lot a lot
of people chalk up
whatever faults they have with electro
not really on jamie foxx's performance
but
on the direction they took that
character and the writing of that
character
which is fair because we all know jamie
foxx is a wonderful wonderful actor he's
an oscar-winning performer for a reason
still that being said you know like him
returning his electro
i'm more like okay
all right sure cool cool like it's
surprising
it wasn't what i was ever expecting to
hear i'm actually more surprised by that
than hearing andrew garfield would be
making an appearance in here because i
think we've all been suspecting you know
with
spider-verse coming out with multiverse
of madness coming out that they are
opening up the multiverse
of the marvel cinematic universe which
would allow for
potential crossovers like this like what
dc is clearly doing with their shows and
now with the flashpoint movie
they're evidently i mean at least with
the spiderman terrain
yeah they're evidently trying to capture
some of that
i feel like this idea of having a
lecture return kind of goes to support
more theories that we've sort of been
speculating on and all of us have been
going after
for quite some time right back to that
morbius trailer with seeing the
spider-man that was the tobey maguire
spider-man
jk simmons he did talk about his
portrayal as j
jonah jameson how that is a different
jay jonah jameson he was pretty
clear about that didn't he come out
recently and say that that
was a different jay jonah jameson but
they wanted to keep him
spiritually in nature with the comics
and what we saw with the raimi version
so that's not the same one yeah exactly
so we might
very well see a totally different take
on electro
through jamie foxx again which i mean
would be an
interesting thing to do not only because
hey you know yeah you're bringing back
an established piece of continuity but
also
yeah if you let him do something new
with that that's gonna be kind of the
first time
i think we'll have seen that happen here
where it's like come back
make a new stamp on your character yeah
or they could
be opening up the actual multiverse that
he could be the exact same electro from
amazing spider-man 2 and maybe
tom holland's version of peter parker
has made his way into that universe
where
spider-man is not this hated fugitive
for healing the hero mysterio you know
god
and maybe this will even tie in with
morbius and maybe that won't just be a
nod
in the morbius trailer with that version
of toby maguire spider-man but that
actually is like oh
no they they got here maybe vulture went
there too
so that's what i mean like all these
things of marketing
have been making all these questions
sort of arise and i kind of feel like
this whole thing with jamie foxx sort of
just feeds more into that
oh yeah because yeah it just makes you
wonder as to whether they're gonna just
do a big old mishmash
or whether they're going to kind of yeah
do some weird re-brand or whatever and
it's fun to watch because now dc
marvel they're both doing some kind of
big multiverse
you know swing right now um
oh thwip thwip
a pun fun i gotta come up with some more
now
i'm kind of there with you in the same
way of being kind a little non-plussed
but like pleasantly
surprised and i guess what i'm hoping
for is
it's funny if j jonah jameson is a
different take on the same character i
guess it makes me wonder more because
part of me goes
are they going for pragmatism here i
know that they've had the sinister six
in the back of their mind for so long
and they've introduced
several of those characters in several
of these spider-man attempts
and were they sitting here going well we
got to bring electro back but we've
already had a recent electro but now
that we're doing the multiverse why
don't we just bring him in instead you
know like
and i feel like the spider-man franchise
that of all the ones in the mcu
outside of wanda and dr strange at this
moment
in conjunction with the fact that
spider-man
already has established into the
spider-verse in conjunction with that
we have you know like we've already done
like the multiple timeline thing with
endgame explored you have dr strange
multiverse of madness coming out
everything has to sort of just get
cleared up at a certain point the thing
is they could kind of
uh they can kind of backpedal on the
whole jay jonah jameson thing if they
really wanted to
because they didn't make it clear and
far from home outside of jk
simmons's interview they don't make it
crystal clear
in um in in the movie itself no
and so like well they could just no that
is the same one
yeah yeah [ __ ] like that which wouldn't
make sense
but they can if they want if they want
to take actors who played those
characters
already and put them over here as
opposed to like actually tie
in the universe as it's instead giving a
a new version of them if you have jk
simmons playing jay jones jameson but a
different version
this could very well just be that with
electro yeah
however i'd actually be more excited at
the prospect of them
making this the same electro from the
amazing spider-man 2
world from that earth you know if the
mcu is earth 616 if this is some other
earth and then
also with how spider-man far from home
granted mysterio
is not actually from the multiverse he's
not actually from a multiverse but he
used that concept
and they already teased the minds with
that yeah yes with the possibility
of that assuming mysterio was probably
still
alive maybe this does open up the portal
in some way but
what excites me about the possibility of
this actually being the same
electro from amazing spider-man 2 is we
are one step
closer to getting the crossover that i
don't want with toby mcguire
tom holland and andrew garfield we gotta
get that going and if they could keep
that
like man if they have like a scene of
that and we never learn about that
that would be the most exciting thing in
the world yeah yeah it really would be
and to me
i feel like it is a more exciting
prospect to have him theoretically
playing that same character because if
he's not then it's
literally just casting news whereas if
you're bringing the character back that
at least
says something because even if the jay
jonah jameson we saw in the amazing
in spider-man far from home isn't the
one they're still
clearly banking on your familiarity with
the original one from raymie and it
seems like they're yeah they want to
take advantage of that
yeah that spells a certainly kind of
kooky fun
broad thing they could be doing to move
forward and and yeah
like at the best of what this news has
to offer
it sounds pretty fun and it also seems
like a smart business move because it's
like we've seen
uh zack snyder talking about
acknowledging the ryan reynolds green
lantern and now it's gonna make it so
that
this amazing spider-man 2 that lost so
much money
now people are going to have to go watch
it if they want the complete continuity
so like it's also a smart business move
it's smart and then also you know the
fact that this is tom holland's
franchise is a different spider-man
franchise than the other ones that we've
gotten already
maybe instead of having to reset up
electro all over again
we have someone who we're already
familiar with so you can actually
speed much faster to
i said that sentence weird but you can
get much quicker towards sinister six
yeah if you haven't already like oh we
already know elektra
we know from this previous one yeah and
even if the origin wasn't perfect you've
still got it and that's not the most
important part of all these characters
so yeah we can just use that from the
past and move on yeah
although there's a version of this that
just sounds hilarious to me
if uh this is the worst spider-man
movie to come from the tom hall
and it is the one that apparently marvel
is taking the lead on production force
so if it turns out to be a mess that's
going to be embarrassing which is even
more surprising to me if they have jamie
foxx returning because
i feel like kevin feige it sounds like a
sony move
i know not a marvel move yeah exactly
that kind of baffles my mind even more
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens
right now a lot of this is being
reported as a hundred percent confirmed
but we we don't know exactly yet we
could get a piece of information
slightly off he could be playing a
different person but what makes it funny
to me is if it is the worst one is that
he will have struck out three times
nah he's gonna play miles morales but i
would think
i think in terms of my love for jamie
foxx the performer i would be very
happy for him to get an opportunity to
do electro
properly in a role that uh is feels
redeemed from
whatever lackluster one that we felt
with amazing spider-man 2.
this probably would be the better fit
maybe electro is the one who opens up
the portal
you know could be because he's got
electrical powers and most portals need
electricity
because i feel like we're likely to
assume that tom holland would go to
that universe whereas i i bet they would
probably bring
electro into here yeah so things are
bleeding who's the freaking villain guys
is it craving the hunter who is it
it's every villain all the villains are
the villain who is it the multi
verses this is the first almost almost
official confirmed
news of of a villain to be in spider-man
3. so
we'll see we shall see it's just like i
thought that i thought like they were
going to start shooting this very soon
so
how could it be a main villain i don't
know and like to just be in talks for it
it's just
some confusing pieces of information
maybe he'll just cameo
maybe that's what i mean this might not
even be a big deal maybe there will be a
hallway of multi-dimensions and just
down
one hall there he is it could be like
ronan the accuser in
freaking captain marvel like it could be
the exact same situation
we're like oh he didn't really do much
he was just nearby contextually speaking
all right guys well generally are you
excited about this news what
doors are you hoping this opens up if he
is indeed coming back as a lecturer
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell
please leave your thoughts down below
hit that like button blah blah blah
patron of the day shout out
i would like to shout out anissa oliva
ah
now anisa denisa today has been quite
a busy day with shooting and editing a
lot
and then i have on the schedule all day
today all day
to unbox this film underneath this at a
certain point and put on patreon a gift
you sent me
so much keeps delaying that there's
things that are dropping
all right and i will get to it
we will at least film it today so i
promise that whatever is in here i'm
i already love it i'm already in love
with whatever's in here i have no idea
anything other than just this but um she
said this is for my birthday
so i don't want anything else other than
this for you
that's what i wanted to hear john i want
you to have this
but anissa thank you for the countless
gifts
you are my personal santa but a sexy
version
so thank you for being you and esa love
the hell out of you
i will get to this box i promise
[Music]
santa